yeah she's got a helmet on here
she i've been like scrolling like on the
whatsapp yeah
yeah why didn't they say two days ago
then i thought you don't have this
wait what's this for
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to relationship goals i'm phil
johnson your host and i'm with a12funny
this guy is gonna be the judge jewelry
and executioner relationship goals is a
tournament where coppers go head to head
to see who's got the most solid couple
if they win this they go to the
semi-final if they win at the semi-final
they go to the final and if they win the
final
jordan ruby
even though this money you know
but more importantly as my judges
demonstrating they win a hundred free
firewave pizzas
and whoever wins just know about me and
them was friends from time to go i'm
saying this hopefully
you're gonna say you know i'm gonna try
blowing
anyway let's go
my name is chelsea and i'm here for the
cash prize my name is matthew and i too
am here for the cash prize my name is
lauren and i'm here because i really
want to win the money
my name is chris and i want to win the
money too so we've been together roughly
two years officially officially yeah
yeah two years but together two and a
half years is your partner
the one very personal
i hope so because i'm really not trying
to
tell someone else my favorite color
again
i'm really not
what do you think ditto
yeah
i'd say so yeah here's the one
guys are you ready yeah ready
i said are you ready yeah we ready okay
for round one the boy is going to
predict what the women would say but for
that to happen the women need to go into
the soundproof room so we've got some z
technology beats headphones over there i
need you to put them on and play some
music and then swap phones so you can't
cheat
first question guys
how much money would your girlfriend
probably leave you for
i'm gonna go with you matthew a million
pounds
you think so you're saying so if i come
to your girl yeah with 300k
300 big ones and say yo this is just
300k hold that but you could never see
matthew again
you think she ain't taking that 300k and
i've changed my answer
you can change your answer if you want
it
got to be to be fair i know she'll get
back chaser so she's a back chaser all
right like that no no not like that no
like that is
[Music]
[Applause]
it's funny because she's probably
listening to that right now
all right so what's your automatic guy
ten bucks ten bags
ten bags bro
i could take a rack
[ __ ] you're not even worth a rolly bro
i i you know what let's just say a
hundred let's just say hundred okay
just tell us have your own mind though
don't let us
no no
say if you say a hundred and then she
comes and says a meal you can't moan so
it's
a hundred your final answer yeah yeah
looking in 100 all right so 100k chris i
just know she's gonna go for like the
smallest amount possible so
i'll see like a grand
angle confidence man
i guarantee i better be some like a
small number can we get some violins
please
he ain't got confidence that's a little
prepared yours were a man said a grand
so you really need to win this thing
wow
his whole life's at stake
okay so he said 1k
question two what are you guys most uh
most likely to argue about i'll go with
chris first
date night
date night it's always date night why
why why some [ __ ] at date night your
[ __ ]
i can't plan a date night like to save
my life so what happens what do you
normally do i just kind of like try to
wing it
wing it i always wing it yeah so like
give me an example
so
put something you get a towel you fling
it outside no no no no no no i make the
effort
so what have you done
i think my last like oh god
i think that says a lot to be fair
can i be quite general with it
anything you want
the world is your old stuff petty
i mean
petty stuff
yeah
petty stuff can you elaborate please
like you calling her a bag chaser and
then she's like
actually yeah to be fair we just take
the piss at each other a lot to be fair
so you have quite a fun relationship
yeah we don't really argue like that oh
you don't really argue that well we need
a definitive answer because that's not
why i asked you to ask you what do you
argue about so think of that one time
that you argued and point at that and
then tell us that that where to you okay
cool
what one of your girlfriend's family
members do you just think is
peng
and i'm going to go with you
moms is watching so if it's her let her
know
i'll have to say your mum to be fair i'm
not going to say anyone else
the rest of like uncles and straight
okay well you could we don't know which
you know i mean
it is 20 22. yeah yeah i mean yeah you
could swing both ways yeah i'm saying
you could if you which sell yours so
you're going to i'll go
okay matthew
what one of your girlfriends family
members
do you think it's pink
sister
oh
man went close with it sister acting
even like that even like that don't get
too even like that but you can't see it
you put me in the situation oh okay so
we got the grandma and we got the nephew
okay i respect that
girls
can you come back please
we need you to answer some questions for
us please question one
i'm gonna ask you okay
great
how much money would you leave your
boyfriend for
damn she went
honestly
you know what
10k
he he wasn't ready
wait what
was i right well you was right and you
was wrong and you was right and you was
wrong
okay but he did change his answer why
i thought you came up with me a bit more
than that i don't know that
okay after you're trying to get the bag
you know what i'm saying
because that's true
lauren
how much would you have said
that you would have left chris for
a million pound a million pounds
[Laughter]
chrissy boy here said 1k
that's how much confidence he has in you
i'm just people
yeah
basically
he said he would have said a penny
no i didn't say a penny but
look at your mouth twitching
he said he would have said a penny but
then i was like a penny and then he was
like all right all right a grand oh
you're not a student
he brought you to this game show because
he wants to show you that he's got a
ground so you don't leave him so do that
what you will but we'll move on to
question two and question two was
what are you guys most likely to argue
about we'll ask you first
in putting his clothes on the floor
and putting his clothes on the floor
yeah so you say he's a bit messy
yeah or would you say it gets messy in
the bedroom i don't know i'm just trying
to figure it out that was a bar still i
don't know i was a boss though
[Music]
no i'm going to say
like mess
mess in the bedroom mess in the bedroom
yeah
all right cool mess in the bedroom
it gets messy in the bedroom okay yeah
yeah um and you was absolutely wrong
anyway
moving on what would you say i'd
probably say about what we would eat
just the food
about what we're gonna do
until she's spoken please she spoke she
said she said eat she's living still
don't react please all right but so
because she could change her answer do
you know what i'm saying no i'm pretty
confident in that okay so she said it
yeah
that was correct all right then so this
is round three
third question and it got a bit saucy
diesel was very happy to answer this
question i must say they answered it in
no speed of a second and it was which
wanna use like family members
do they think is pink and that is the
actual wording i'm gonna go with lauren
first
but i'm like the only girl in the family
so the only only thing that he would
have said is my mom okay so what do you
do you want to go with that answer yeah
you don't have a grandma you don't have
a nan
so you say your mom yeah yeah so you'd
say he looks at your mom and thinks
she's peng yeah okay cool okay so she
said mom and she was correct
yeah christmas
and now they're slapping hands about
attractive without mommies
oh weird
house crazy oh my god
okay so which one of your family members
would matthew here
thinks peng
and by the way
he was very happy about uh yeah why
aren't you so happy
like
he was excited like when i said it he
got excited i could feel his heart i
could feel the chair though this is why
i would leave you for 10k
anyways
my sister
okay
do you have more than one sister is it
just the one no i only have one sister
so what's why have you ever saw him like
checking her out or anything while you
come to that conclusion
nah but now i'm gonna have to go check
his search history what are you doing
basically
he said that your sister is like 10 10
still and he said that if he saw your
sister first it would have been peace
but anyway really
[Laughter]
big cup
that i can reveal
is
so that's 2-1
to you guys remember the scores cause he
has short-term memory loss yes and
let's move in to round two
[Music]
okay so can you look at each other
please
this one again
all right if your boyfriend was single
what part of this
what part of each other do you think he
would be most attracted to
look at the way he's like sizing each
other
um
i'd say
your lips
okay
these are looking like they're looking
at each
should other get a room or
your boyfriend's uh just over there her
bunda so question two
if you had to change one thing about
your boyfriend what would it be
i got this his ability to use a clock
like like to calculate time oh we can't
talk he no he's late to everything
everything
he takes him two hours to walk out the
door and he's not doing anything
sarah serious well thank you for turning
up on time today yeah honestly i'm
surprised he did so
in like a single phrase what would you
say um
talent time
time management yeah
he doesn't
talk about his feelings enough
so he doesn't share his emotions no yeah
yeah share his emotion like do a little
role play of you trying to make him open
up yeah how does it go i say
how he feeling or like if we're having a
tiff or whatever or if he's upset
because i would just shrug his shoulders
you real gangster is yeah yeah yeah
sounds fun sounds like a real
entertainer question three
so what is that one thing
that like nearly pushed you to the edge
like you was going to leave your
boyfriend over so what's that one thing
he's done what you either left him and
got back with him or you was going to
leave him i'm going to ask you first i
wouldn't blame him for this but it was
something that pushed me to the point
when his ex kind of like started to come
at me not in like a physically not
physically yes
but like
trying to
say that i was the reason behind things
like of them in their relationship and
i'm like i didn't even know you but
that's cool so just to get this straight
his ex blamed you for them breaking up
something like that yeah so did
did he did she did it
he didn't really like defend me
you know
what about you laura
not making enough effort yeah just like
going out
so you don't think your boyfriend makes
an effort
how long have you been together
it's okay we can write
i won't tell him a thing this is um
attorney client privilege yeah no he
would never know two years so you've
been together for two years with someone
who don't make an effort i didn't say
that
moving on don't make an effort okay
thank you um
boys can we have the boys back
please
so
question one
was
if your boyfriend was single
what would he say
the other person sitting here on these
chairs best feature is
so could you turn to lauren please and
could you turn to chelsea could you have
a quick pier
because i want you to let me know
what part of them you think's buff
you know chris yeah i saw him see what
he liked and then
and then act like he was thinking so we
saw it and he was like and then he was
like he saw his girl look at him and he
was
um out
i need to like
yeah
all right so chris i'm gonna go with you
first scene as i know you already know
the answer i i'd say ask yeah
oh swear it's like that
you're going for the
bunda huh all right matthew
what are you thinking about lauren what
are you saying
have a look go on don't be shy all right
she don't bite unless you ask there too
[ __ ] um
i'm gonna go with eyes i'm gonna go with
eyes so he's saying they're looking in
her eyes like chris actually not
actually you know what i see no you know
what yeah no actually
i can't like
wonder at the end of the day
trumps everything my eyes are nice eyes
okay so you're saying you're saying you
like her eyes anna bunda
no no no no no no no no no
so even though we asked you for one
thing
you gave us two so you're saying you're
feeling our eyes
indecisive man no no
i'm just indecisive have you seen any
more no no no no no no no no
i can confirm
that
chris
you was incorrect
i thought you would like her lips so
lauren thought you would like her lips
but no you was all upon their ass okay
and talk about these lips mate you
was nearly incorrect but then you turned
it to the bottom
i wouldn't be too happy though because
oh [ __ ] yeah you did say you liked her
eyes and you've been staring into
another woman's eyes and
i just i was just i was just on a
game you know i was just trying to think
clever so round two question two
what's the one thing you would change
about your boyfriend
my height
high
your height i'm not even sure you know
mine's not even so
you said your height how tall are you
six foot yeah and man said he's high
i don't know why i said hi are you gonna
be stressed you said five seconds after
like are you giving me 15 seconds in
total yeah i need more times i think
it's okay i'm six or five
okay
throw it out there by the way girls he's
six foot five we asked
lara in the same question i'd say she's
changing my eyebrows or something like
that try to shape him up or something i
don't know
he's trying to like pluck him and
stuff like that so let me get this
straight
the first thing you think about when you
think the one thing she would change
about you i think that's the one is your
eyebrows eyebrows
yeah
she did say that she was like
so she's always trying to pluck your
eyebrows yeah i can let you know that
both y'all got your answers absolutely
wrong
because
lauren
she said what i can't read your writing
emotions that's what lauren said it's a
bit like yeah she said um so she wants
you to be more emotional you got it
wrong as well
your answer
was time management
look at me knows he knows he said oh
man said time and that i've got like
five rollies for no reason
i can't lie that's
let's move on to question three
i said to your girlfriends what's the
one thing that nearly made you leave
your man like you was about to go
because this person was just
you like
close to the edge
and what do you think
lauren answered chris i'd say it'd be
like it's not like spending too much
time with my mates or something like
that like going on too many times
too many nights out right yeah
two minutes put down too many nights out
nephew it's all on you no pressure
being too clingy
being too clingy who's too clingy you or
you yeah oh you're a little clicky
clinging onto that balloon
you just wrap around
yeah obviously obviously
so at the start when she was seeing
other people she asked you to just like
give her some space basically is that
what you're saying
because basically lauren said that
you're not making enough of an effort
and she was going to leave you because
you're just a crap boyfriend in every
way that's what she said it was her
words not mine and um
your girlfriend i was scared no
this one was a paragraph
oh my god so like
basically like
matt's acts you know like x
totally a [ __ ]
but not
totally saying that i did not like
i'm the reason they broke up and it's
like i know you know
but it's not my fault so
in a little paraphrase what i would say
is like
from the cayman islands it's like
looking at the same person
she basically said you know he's not
defending that was her um you did not
defend there bro you didn't have her
back are you gonna back your bedroom
you're getting me you didn't
seem like nuts bro you do you had all
that six foot height
but you took flight
you know what i'm saying
well uh you've both done pretty poorly
however
luckily to um i might say uh chelsea
chelsea
and mata exactly to be exact
that's the one point that you guys got
so what that round goes to matt and
chelsea but the funny thing about this
was it wasn't chelsea's bundle was it
it was lauren's wonderful i was not
sorry it was lara's so let's just
randomly
please
guys so many bundles going on in my
brain
so the scores are in and the judge can
conquer that it's
three one
simmer and chelsea okay come on man
chris come on hey look at that [ __ ] no
no look
first and foremost i need you to take
out your phones please swap unlock and
swap phones for the first point please
so we're good to go everyone's unlocked
and swapped yeah all right then so
that's a point so give them both a point
please
second test
could you
go to the whatsapp and type in
their ex's name
and this let's have a little gander at
their last
conversation
oh you don't have an x he's my first
boyfriend oh
go to the she's got a helmet on here
she i've
cloud and this is a bit awkward i didn't
expect this to happen i thought you was
looking through context that was all
guys i know
jesus no no no it's not it's not bare
masculine names you know bad puns and
harry's that's what i'm saying yeah do
wash your ex's name no no no no no no no
type it in
you seem a bit nervous i don't think do
you want some water i don't have a
conversation with him that wasn't the
question
like the taj yeah is that is that can
you confirm that's x's name i'm not
gonna like we didn't even talk about
that oh you didn't talk traumatic oh
what's the what's the point i mean
it's all gone from my phone do you want
like a different name
we could go okay you know what she's
just choosing different yeah that we
ain't going for the taj mahal so flip
him we can go to my man and if mamma is
there
have you gone to his exes
and
and the conversation's all clear yeah
yeah both ears will get the point so
give them both a point because they did
go in the whatsapp
well done
all right now i want you zlat to make
your way over to instagram please
instagram look look look at these guys
synchro you don't have instagram all
right all right wait do you have
snapchat no man it's all gone you don't
have any 2022 you don't have snapchat
let me explain what you use
you don't have no social media bro
how do you even know me
i don't
oh snap
nah nah i wasn't even a part of that
i'm playing bro i'm playing i've got
instability
so i can log in like on the website the
hotspot you make that's it
streams oh hotspot you can download that
but like i'm not using it right now
quick quick
[Applause]
yeah instagram ain't no
nothing too much too
every time a man says
it's not too much their story i use that
on each other's instagram they use that
on each other's phones yeah go to the dm
please
you can say no by the way
he's already scrolled through like 25
minutes
yeah we've been in this this is for the
best oh man's got enough
notifications popping already in there
[Music]
12 accounts and he's verified on seven
of them
who is this guy
oh bro
he's verified whatever they're doing
so is the dms looking um copacetic over
there would use that is everything
looking crystal clear yeah no there's no
dilly no dahlia over there yeah what to
go through to be honest yeah but what
about her what did you say there's a lot
to go through oh
man said dilly dally but lawrence is
willy wally
wow so you have a lot of dm's lauren
does it go
down in the dm this my friends oh
oh she's my friend a friend
long day
one
long decade not even a long day long
decade who's that darling
it's my friend
[Laughter]
it's darn bro chris just when you called
a friend yo
well yeah yeah yeah yeah how could a
friend's voice is always good it's never
some nice guy oh hey guys how are you
doing bro i like you it's always
one yeah yeah yeah
last week
wait what's this for
no you because you say you don't have ig
right yeah but like
why i
the most recent one what my boy
tyrone
yeah but you say you don't use you could
have deleted whatever whatever else i
was on my laptop that's where
instagram on the laptop
yeah bro i had to nah if you're using
your ig on your laptop something so no
no
he's doing quick
wait let him let him explain himself
and think he's been messaging bad girls
and then deleting the messages and then
lying and saying he ain't got it let him
explain himself
so obviously obviously sometimes you've
got to take a little break from social
media and that yeah it can be toxic you
know it is yeah but at the same time
obviously it's a it's probably the best
tool out here so you've got to stay in
contact you've got to stay connected and
whatnot
it
are you happy with everything over there
are you happy with everything yeah
you like did
very good in that last light round i'm
surprised the scores are
6-4
to matt and chelsea
well done
so that means you'll be coming to the
semi-finals
to battle it out with another group that
wins hi and chris and lauren i'm sorry
but you are the weakest links
you would definitely not relationship
goals and you should break up
immediately goodbye
hit us
all right thank you guys that has been
relationship goals
episode two
joining us again for episode three
that was that was the room
like
i knew as soon as i came back that we
had no hope to be cornerstone
he just
says and doesn't think
if he just took his time like like matt
did he would have come up with the right
answers
your relationship goes in yeah for sure
definitely
going to make it to the end don't worry
we'll do it you'll see us again if they
don't win
then hit me up matt
you've been eyeing her up all day
at the two of us i think chris was the
weakest yeah i'll agree with that i'm
not gonna i didn't i made deep and
meaningful answers and he just went
is it the first thing that came to my
head yeah i've found three girls already
all this year
recently he's
what a friend my friend
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you